Forbes just released its list of
America's wealthiest celebrities and
there are some mind-blowing surprises in
the top five crazy that Beyonce didn't
make the list but jay-z did at nine
hundred million he's number five and
it's even crazier who's tied with him
Kylie Jenner Forbes says she's worth
just shy of a billion yep
way more than Kim it's crazy because
we're in the same business nine hundred
million dollars at just 21 years old it
puts her on track to become the youngest
self-made billionaire ever Jenner owns a
hundred percent stake in Kylie cosmetics
which has racked up over 630 million in
makeup sales since it launched two years
ago at number four Michael Jordan he's
worth an estimated 1.7 billion from his
sales of his famous Footwear and a 90
percent ownership of the Charlotte
Hornets that stake alone is worth some a
hundred million dollars
I love brecht lady o also loves making
major dough she's number three and since
Weight Watchers now called WWJ and Kate
Hudson that's helping boost shareholder
Oprah's wealth to 2.8 billion I love you
[Music]
so who beat out Oprah doesn't pay much
Star Wars creator George Lucas at 5.4
billion he's number 1 and light-years
ahead of number 2 Steven Spielberg with
3.7 billion that's thanks largely due to
his Lucasfilm sale which went to Disney
for a little over four billion dollars
back in 2012 well the force was with him
and so were those dollars well one big
star who missed the cut is Ellen
DeGeneres because she's worth only an
estimated 400 million dollars I mean
poor thing what's that one gonna do with
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]